Imagine something your agent didn't prod
was wrong.
Called the wrong tool, it wrote the
wrong thing, and now suddenly your team
is on on correlation to figure out what
actually went wrong.
Pretty common, right?
Now, as for the standard engineering
response, your gut will tell you to pull
the raw prompt from the telemetry logs,
pass it to the same model using the same
prompt, and run it locally to isolate
the bug. Which we'll all do. And
surprisingly, it will work as well. Run
it again, it will work again. You'll run
it 10 more times, it will be just
perfect every time. But now let's talk
about that one run which cost you, and
that will be gone. You can't reproduce
it. And if you can't reproduce it, you
can't debug it. And if you can't debug
it, you can't promise it won't happen to
your next customer or user, right?
Now, I am Tisha. I have Sachin with me
as my co-presenter. We both run agents
against real production backends. You
know, the kind of place where a bad
write isn't, "Oh well, done it again."
It's you on a call with a customer
explaining where the data actually went.
This whole talk is going to be about
that one thing you lose the second an
agent goes haywire in production, which
is being able to reproduce it.
That will be our not start for the next
10 minutes to follow.
Now let's look at how this actually
blows up. You've got an agent hooked to
a broker API, which is the scenario I'm
taking. The user says, "Hey, sell $1,000
of stock."
Now comes the interesting part. Instead
of doing the math, the agent sells the
raw number 1,000 and dumps it straight
into the quantity field. Guess what? It
sells 1,000 shares instead.
Now, at of 190 bucks a share, a $1,000
Intel will become how much? A $190,000
disaster, right?
And the terrifying part is that the API
or my inferring returned a clean 200
okay in 30 milliseconds. We got zero
exceptions, zero alerts.
If you see the trade
is completely wrong. But, your
dashboards are sitting there perfectly
green, perfectly flawless.
Then, such a scenario as we last
discussed comes up. What's the first
thing which you would do to try and fix
this? The reflex here is to, you know,
just turn the model temperature down to
absolute zero, assuming greedy decoding
will make everything deterministic,
right? But, that's a complete
misconception. Setting the temperature
to zero doesn't fix a broken reasoning
path. It just means the model is going
to make the exact same logical error,
the exact same way, at the exact same
time, and honestly,
even worse than that.
To back up the scenario we just
discussed, look at the engineering
threads on Reddit and Hacker News. The
hard data shows that temperature zero
isn't even truly deterministic on a
hardware level. Running the same prompt
a thousand times can still return dozens
of completely different responses just
due to the underlying GPU
non-determinism and the MOE
architectures which are there.
So, to understand why this actually
happens, we'll have to look at it from
first principles.
It comes down to four simple things.
One,
sampling determinism isn't system
determinism.
Temperature zero just means always take
the argmax, but it doesn't guarantee
that the underlying scores stay
identical run to run.
Two, floating point math isn't
associative. The order you add your
decimal matters, right? But a tiny shift
in matrix operation alters the final
logits and which in turn will flip the
winning token.
Three,
it's not a concurrency issue. Run the
same matrix multiplication alone on a
GPU a thousand times and I'll guarantee
you'll get this exact same bits. So the
real culprit is batch invariance here
because a request gets grouped with
whatever else hits the server that
millisecond.
Four, mixture of experts routing has the
exact same bottleneck. Experts have
strict capacity limits. If a batch
overflows a specific subnetwork, tokens
get rerouted.
Whether the token makes the cut depends
entirely on the traffic you got batched
with.
So the ultimate takeaway here is that
chasing text outputs is a losing battle,
completely. We don't need the model to
return the exact same token back every
time. We just need our system to execute
the exact same state transition.
Which means we've been asking the wrong
question all along, right? The wrong
question is how do I make the model
deterministic? And I've seen teams
burning weeks on that and walk away
deciding the system is just unknowable.
The right question is how do I debug and
retest a run I can't
reproduce because determinism was never
the North Star. Debugging was.
Two words we keep mixing up, which I'll
talk about now, is bitwise determinism
and replayability. Bitwise determinism
is same input, same output. That's
controllability. You're not getting it
from a hosted API, and you don't
actually want it because the randomness
is what makes the model good. Like once
the model explores more, you'll get more
creative answers. The other one is
replayability, which is re-validates a
run that already happened well enough to
debug it. That's observability. You
don't need the model deterministic. You
need the run recorded, and you don't
freeze the model. You capture what it
did.
Now, the question which we are all
thinking about is where do you record?
For sure, not at the network layer
because half your agent will never touch
the network, the local retrieval, the
in-process tools, the memory, and the
parts that do not shred under streaming
and async.
Record at the boundary instead because
you need to capture what enters each
node and what leaves it. The meaning of
each step and not the packets. What
replay adds here is a deterministic CI
where you stop the model, you rerun the
exact failure of line with zero model
calls.
Let's talk about the loop end to end
now. It starts with annotation,
recording, visualization, understanding,
fixing, then the part we're working on,
which is deep playing, and finally
verifying.
All right. Let's now see how to bring
the workflow we just discussed into
action.
>> So, we've established that replayability
is a core tenant of productionizing any
AI agent. But, how do we build this in
code?
As a proof of concept for this, what we
have done is we have built something
called Chronicle.
At the heart of Chronicle lies the
concept of a boundary.
Think of a boundary as a bounding box
around any node in your agentic
workflow.
A node can be a tool call. It can be a
call to an LLM or a retrieval from a
rag.
It doesn't matter.
As long as it's a method, it can be
annotated with the boundary annotation.
Now, what does this annotation do? It
ensures that anything that goes into the
method and comes out of the method gets
recorded. So, any input and output pair
will get recorded. On top of that, you
can define parameters like your model
version or the version of the code that
is running so that the entire state
during which the agent run happened gets
frozen and saved as a trace. Now, let's
see this in action.
We've been talking about this stock
selling agent which went haywire in
production. This is a representation of
the same. You have your initial planning
step which takes into account the user
input. It can use the place order tool
to do the actual selling and buying of
the stocks, and then finally it
delegates to the finalize agent which
generates a succinct response for the
end user.
We have annotated all three of these
methods with the boundary annotation.
The first one is a tool, and the second
and the third one is an LLM. Let's run
this.
So, here's what happened. You gave a
user request to sell about $1,000 worth
of Acme stocks.
You have the three nodes. You have the
input and the output recorded for every
one of them. You can see that the LLM
mistook the thousand as the quantity and
generated a tool call of place order
with the symbol Acme and quantity
thousand. And the place order tool
obviously executed this input and sold
$1,000 or 1,000 units of Acme stock at
$190 per piece.
This is where the problem started. Now,
you have a trace for it, but is this all
you can see? No.
We record much more details than this.
So, you can go and see the hyper
detailed JSON for each of the nodes that
the call went into or went out of. You
can see the metadata like the model
version, the sampling versions that was
there in the LLM call. You can see the
input and the output. For example, this
is for the place order tool. You can see
the input went in as a sell of thousand
quantity on Acme, and the output was
obviously that it sold that quantity.
And if you go one step back, you can see
the agent one node
creating that tool call that caused this
entire problem. It created a tool call
to place order with the symbol Acme and
quantity 1,000.
Now, this is all good. You have a
recording, you have a trace, you figured
out what the problem is. Now, what do
you do with it?
You figured out that the problem is the
LLM created a wrong tool call. You
cannot control the LLM. That's what this
entire discussion is about. You cannot
enforce bitwise determinism. What you
can do is you can put guardrails on your
tools to enforce some level of uh
credibility on your production agent.
But, how do you test this? Once you have
built the guardrails, how do you test
it? That is another tenant that Boundary
offers.
Since the Boundary annotation is already
providing a bounding box around your
methods, it can be used to stub your
methods in during testing. So, think of
it like this.
You have a run which is recorded.
That run recorded every input and output
for every node. Now, you have fixed your
code at let's say the tool level, but
you want the rest of the nodes to be
stubbed so that the entire exact stack
trace remains the same.
How do you do it? You run a test suite
with the same trace that was recorded
earlier. You stub every node other than
the node that you changed, and you let
Boundary handle the rest, right? So,
let's see this one in action.
This is your test case. You have loaded
the trace, and you have enabled the
replay mode on Boundary, which allows
Boundary to stub every node that you
want.
So, for example, in this case, you want
to stub the first agent call which
generated the tool output. But, you want
the tool to be run live so that you can
test out your code changes. Once you do
this, you run your agent. Now, another
good thing about Boundary is that since
it's already capturing the output of
your tool as well, you can use it to run
assertions. So, you can take the output
and assert that this time around the
tool call got blocked. So, let's run
this once.
Perfect. So, you can see that agent one,
which was the LLM, was stubbed. You can
see the same input output as the
recorded trace, but the tool and the LLM
ran live. And you can see that for the
tool, this time the output is blocked.
And your assertion on the tool has
passed because the order has blocked.
So, this is the power of merging your
replayability traces with auto-generated
testing and stubbing and assertions.
tool and the LLM. So, we just saw how
Chronicle not only records your agentic
sessions, but it also uses those
recordings as test cases. Now, when we
talk about testing in AI agents, I want
to draw a very clear distinction here.
There are two ways of testing AI agents,
and both of them are equally important.
There's the deterministic testing, and
then the behavioral testing. The
deterministic testing applies to,
obviously, the deterministic nodes of
your agent graph. This could be your
guardrails or your tool calls. Now, this
is exactly where Chronicle shines
because, as we just saw, Chronicle
freezes the entire agent run as a
context. So, you can use the LLM nodes
context to stub the LLM outputs. This
essentially kicks the probability out of
the window, and your entire agent run
can become a test case. This is
rerun-able, and since it never calls the
model, it is free.
On the behavioral side of things,
you measure things like the tone of the
agent or whether the trajectory it took
was right. This is more subjective, and
this is where techniques like LLM as a
judge are better off.
Now, at this point, I want to talk about
the key takeaways.
First, stop chasing bitwise determinism
through the API. The fundamental
principles on which the APIs are built
today do not make this possible.
Second, know what are variables for your
session, for example, your LLM version
or your build ID or your rag chunks, and
make sure that you are logging these.
Third, capture the full envelope. Don't
focus on just the prompt. There are
There are a lot more ingredients that go
into that final response.
Fourth, use the replace to debug.
Make sure that you find the issues, fix
the failures, and then finally, use the
same trace as a test case.
Fifth and final, keep the generation
time variation alive. Don't try to pin
the temperature to zero. After all, that
is what brings the agency into your
agent.
So, the QR on your screen, you can scan
that to get access to the code for
Chronicle and a bunch of nicely written
articles. And finally, thanks again for
your time, and we hope that the traces
that you put today in your agent make
sure that your on-call cycle tomorrow is
much better. Thank you.